Salut les naturalistes !
"Hespérie du dactyle", "Argus bleu",
"Écaille chinée", "Robert-le-Diable"...
Ces noms ne vous disent peut-être rien !
Pourtant, nul doute que vous connaissez tous le
groupe d'insectes auquel ils appartiennent et
pour lequel nous allons dédier ce nouvel épisode
de notre série : "La vie secrète du jardin".
J'ai nommé "Les papillons"
Générique !
Avec plus de 160 000 espèces décrites
dans le monde, on peut estimer aujourd'hui
qu'environ un animal sur dix est un papillon !
Dans un jardin, avec une flore judicieusement
choisie diversifiée, comme ici de la menthe ou
de la sauge, on peut sans difficulté en observer
plusieurs dizaines d'espèces dont certaines
figurent parmi les plus beaux papillons d'Europe.
En tant qu'insecte, les papillons possèdent 3
paires de pattes, 2 paires d'ailes et un corps
en 3 parties avec une tête, un thorax, un abdomen.
La spécificité de leur groupe vient du
fait que leurs 4 ailes et j'ai bien dit 4,
sont couvertes de minuscules écailles colorées.
C'est pour cette raison que les spécialistes
les classent dans l'ordre des lépidoptères.
Ce mot vient du grec ancien, "ptère" signifiant
l'aile et "lépi" voulant dire écailles.
Ces écailles peuvent être quasiment
toutes de la même couleur.
C'est le cas du "Citron", un très joli
papillon avec une robe jaune qui tire
plus ou moins sur le vert selon qu'il
s'agisse d'un mâle ou d'une femelle.
Pour d'autres espèces à l'inverse, ces
écailles peuvent être de différentes couleurs.
Chez le "Paon-du-jour", par exemple, la
face extérieure des ailes est sombre,
ce qui permet aux papillons de se camoufler
sur les trous ou dans les endroits ombragés.
La face intérieure, quant à elle, dévoile
des couleurs très contrastées pour prévenir
de sa toxicité avec des motifs en forme d’œil qui
peuvent dérouter des prédateurs comme les oiseaux.
En quelques années au jardin j'ai pu identifier
une quinzaine d'espèces de papillons.
Je parle ici uniquement de papillons de jour
dont la plupart se reconnaissent avec leurs
ailes tenues à la verticale lorsqu'ils sont
au repos et leurs antennes en forme de massue.
Cependant il ne faut pas perdre de vue
que, sur les quelques 5000 espèces de
papillons décrites en France, 90% sont nocturnes.
Leurs ailes au repos sont généralement rabattues
en toit sur leur abdomen et leurs antennes
sont en forme de plumes, de peignes ou de fils.
Ces différences anatomiques sont
importantes car certains papillons
de nuit peuvent être actif de jours !
C'est le cas du "Moro-sphinx", un papillon
qui se reconnaît facilement
grâce à son vol très rapide.
Il est surtout capable de butiner
sans se poser, en vol stationnaire.
On le surnomme d'ailleurs pour
cette raison le "Sphinx Colibri".
La majorité des papillons dispose d'une
trompe pour aspirer le nectar des fleurs,
si vous souhaitez les attirer au jardin,
la première solution consiste donc à
leurs proposer des plantes nectarifères.
Elles sont une source de nourriture
indispensable pour les papillons adultes.
Bleuets, chardons, lierres, julienne
des dames, lavande, menthe...
Plusieurs dizaines d'espèces sont possibles et
mieux vaut jouer la carte de la diversité que
ce soit pour des fleurs sauvages, des
plantes cultivées ou des aromatiques.
Vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que le
cycle de vie des papillons débute
par un œuf qui donnera naissance à une chenille.
C'est œufs ne sont pas déposés au hasard dans la
végétation et les papillons vont choisir une ou
plusieurs espèces de plantes hôtes pour pondre.
La seconde façon d'attirer des papillons
au jardin est donc de proposer des
plantes nourricières pour leurs chenilles.
A ce titre, l'ortie est un incontournable
cette plante trop souvent arrachées est choisie
par plus de 10 espèces de papillons différents
en France comme le "Paon-du-jour", le
"Robert-le-Diable" ou le "Vulcain".
Le potager aussi peut-être
un refuge pour des chenilles,
je vous laisse par exemple deviner
où aime pondre la "Piéride du chou".
C'est aussi grâce au potager que je sème tous les
ans du fenouil, que je laisse monter en fleurs.
Les corolles sont très attractives pour
de nombreux insectes pollinisateurs et
c'est ici tous les ans que je retrouve les
chenilles d'un superbe papillon, le "Machaon".
Des graminées, les ronces, des arbres
fruitiers peuvent aussi être proposés
et je ne peux que vous inviter à mettre
en place au jardin une zone de friches,
une prairie fleurie ou une haie champêtre.
Elles feront forcément à un moment ou un
autre le bonheur des papillons
à différents stades de leur vie.
Ami.e naturaliste c'est tout pour aujourd'hui !
Je vous remercie pour votre fidélité et je vous
dis à bientôt pour le prochain épisode, ciao !